m
parler d' inique
ce serait le plus chez imagine que je
viens dîner comme ça un soir aux
privilèges
est-ce que tu préférais dîner avec un
sourd muet ou un tableau de bugs c'est
qu'on insinue pourquoi je connais pas le
langage pour les voyous et le bugue le
mec tu peux être cassée pendant qu'ils
voient qu'ils leur ont remplacé par
quelqu'un qu'il reconnaîtrait par les
différents parlements français tu parle
très bien le français
le gros mot français que tu préfères tu
es
est-ce que c'est con merde ou en plus
certaines abbayes merde là que merde
quand les ramener en france je
comprenais pas pourquoi je vous emmène
dans les magasins et les sociétés on
veut pas dire pas celui que doit adopter
comme en france accélérait alors imagine
maintenant que tu rentres chez toi un
soir tu vois ton jules au lit i'm avec
vanessa paradis
pour elle c'est pas possible aussi c'est
avec le centre et les mines les clients
de cette grande vie alors qu'est ce que
tu t'es moche mais c'est faux
commentaires
qu'est ce que tu fais tu les rejoindre
le lit je la tue tu te casses magath à
bord la semaine leur histoire à cet
ennemi que je tue mèze l6 touche pas à
mon dieu c'est affronter liminiana
régime soient obligés de faire l'amour
sourit jette un fusil sur la tempe tu
peux pas faire l'amour avec un mec les
eaux ici très jolie jamais fait l'amour
avec une fille peut pas être que ça nous
fait l'amour est une césure en
californie quand même c'est pas que le
cheval pays où les gens l'espère oui la
californie oui l'amérique par sommer
légal non mais ça me suis jamais le jeu
mais pour moi c'est comme l'héroïne
gérer les cas cités ne fait pas de sel
mais des filles je sais pas alors qu'une
et si les jolies ou avec très laid mais
je dois dire un excellent et quand même
apprécié connect
comment ça dégoûte à ce point là
alors je sais pas vous mais je suis
obligé je vais faire avec ce que je
connais si j'aime pas nous souvent avec
un déclic va fermer les yeux tu connais
renault et goldman
oui je les connais tu vas qui s'était
jusque là et on imagine que tu dois
partir dans un vaisseau spatial pendant
quatre ans en apesanteur élémentaire
flop avec 4 lequel tu choisis pas quand
même
goldman oui pourquoi moi non je ne
supportais pas savoir dernière question
d'allumer la radio on se dit que la
bombe atomique va tomber dans cinq
minutes
qu'est ce que j'ai fait c'est des choix
les cinq dernières minutes qui précèdent
c'est à dire votre connaissance moment
où pousse tout le monde à mourir tard
anthony danse invite à la bombe noire
alors il est lui aussi très difficile
pour tous ceux qui l'ont applaudi et
salué regarder mais je pense que je
prendrai mon maigre mais traîne en libye
avec la france la minuk sommes vraiment
son feu vert à une prise puisque l'amour
est la plus grande prière